hello and welcome to the take with
Sophie Ridge live at nine here in the
hearts of Westminster
prime minister and a government feel
increasingly Boxed In by the markets the
cost of government debt Rising sharply
again today by that big package of tax
cuts the chancellor says that he's
standing by in the search for growth by
disastrous polls and a buoyant
opposition but most dangerously by her
own MPS many of whom still seem deeply
concerned after meeting this trust this
evening and perhaps by her own words
today as she promised absolutely no
spending cuts so how to make the sums
add up and save her Premiership we'll
bring you takes from all sides over the
next 60 minutes
I'm genuinely unclear about what
like Mr Speaker I'm genuinely unclear
as to what the labor party's policy is
on our energy price guarantee
it was a tough first week back at Pam
Hughes for his trust but with a row over
possible spending cuts to paying for tax
cuts this may be the most important
Exchange
during her leadership contest the Prime
Minister said and I quota exactly I'm
very clear I'm not planning public
spending reductions is she going to
stick to that
absolutely absolutely
[Applause]
what the state of the economy and the
PM's precarious position remained top of
the agenda this evening we'll be
discussing all of that with our viewers
panel who will be joining us uh later on
in the program there is a empty box here
we're hoping that Hannah is going to
happily wrestle with her internet
problems and join us good to see the
rest of you looking forward to talking
to you later on the program we also have
some top guests for you including the
conservative MP John Barron the former
Minister guy Opperman Labor's Shadow
business secretary Jonathan Reynolds
plus we'll also be talking to a leading
Economist and much more besides coming
up on the take
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
has been prime minister for just 37 days
and I actually find this quite hard to
believe but today was only her second
pmqs in the job and yet the pressure
continues to build with another Rocky
day for the markets with the cost of
government borrowing going up again the
PM met her own back benchmps this
evening to try and reassure them after
weeks of difficult polls for the
conservatives but of course when MPS are
worried about their own jobs it means
the PM isn't secure in hers there may be
an air of mutiny in the ranks already so
let's create straps crack straight on
shall we we are going to start with the
best bits of the week so far
now the chancellor is bringing forward
publication of his medium-term fiscal
plan by three weeks the bank of England
has announced a second intervention in
the government debt markets in 24 hours
will it be austerity by the back door
Simon Clark how can you help the most
vulnerable Chloe Smith no other
government is sabotaging their own
country's economic credibility as this
government is we've got pro-growth
pro-enterprise pro-business
conservatives on one side and the
anti-growth Coalition on the other side
my message to the funds involved and all
the firms involved in Manchester's funds
you've got three days left now you've
got to get this done hello good evening
the pound has fallen sharply this
evening amid growing concern about the
UK economy you shouldn't be surprised by
some of the moves markets do move
quickly it's a 30-year Guild that's the
uh the long guilt look at that you can
see what's happened there it is back
above the level where it was when the
bank announced its intervention what we
will make sure is that over the medium
term the debt is falling but we will do
that not by cutting public spending but
by making sure we spend public money
well when will she stop ducking
responsibility do the right thing and
reverse her Kamikaze budget which is
causing so much pain Mr Speaker I think
the last thing we need is a general
election
Wellness trust has been meeting
conservative MPS at the 1922 committee
at this evening and by most accounts it
was a pretty bruising encounter
described by one MP as the worst 1922
they've ever been to so let's speak to a
conservative MP who was at that meeting
John Barron joins us now thank you very
much for being with us on the program
tonight and now I understand that you
may not want to get into details of what
was a private meeting and is there any
sense you can give us about how the
Prime Minister was received by her MPS
well it was a private meeting and I'd
never commented on uh publicly on uh 22
meetings I'm not going to start now but
all I will say share with you Sophie is
that uh you know I before this meeting
I've made my views known as have many
colleagues that we disagreed with the
cut in the 45 or 8p of tax we believe
that benefits should stay linked to
inflation and that the messaging around
the mini budget could have been improved
if only to reassure the market
so this is a new government
um we must focus on what is good the
energy our cap has been welcomed helped
during the pandemic
um with regards to businesses and
individuals was very welcomed lots of
good things happening we all agree and
low tax and growth in order to share
that
um that bigger economic pie particularly
with the less fortunate but we got to
have compassionate conservatism at the
heart of what we do and apparently you
made an intervention at the 1922
committee meeting I understand if it's
something you're not happy to share as
part of a private meeting if you are
happy then obviously please do and
otherwise what is more generally your
opinion of how the prime minister is
performing
I think the Prime Minister I'm not going
to share what happened to the 22 Sophia
I hope you understand
um but but what I think a number of us
are saying is that look I I think very
few people certainly within the
conservative party can disagree with
lower taxes and higher growth
um but the mini budget could have been
um communicated better there was no
hardly any reassurance to the markets
with regards borrowing or spending and
usually there's guidance given in such a
major budget as it turned out to be
um that's got to be improved but also
I would share with you this talk and and
you know the Prime Minister has has said
let's let's I want to hear your views
um but this talk about breaking the link
are between benefits and inflation
um is you know a number of us have said
look the link must stay particularly
during a cost of living crisis uh but
that that plus the fact the Optics of
the 45p rate of tax the original
intention of of of scrapping it it's
just very very poor Optics so we've got
to ReDiscover what we're about and
that's compassionate conservatism
there's a lot going right at the moment
Sophie you know we've got the one of the
lowest unemployment unemployment rates
across Europe certainly far lower than
the EU average we're doing okay in many
areas we just the government just needs
to get its acting together a little bit
with regards to the way it presents its
policies and communicates you're talking
there uh about the link between benefits
and rising in line with inflation
obviously so many people on the lowest
incomes very hard hit by inflation
rising cost of fuel of food and so on
and you were the chair of the uh or not
chair and member of the all-party group
for compassionate politics how do you
think compassionate conservatism is
going at the minute
well I think you know the government is
said it's listening
um we've made these interventions in the
past
um you know a number of us
um made our views known with regards the
scrapping of the 45 rate of PE rate of
tax at this point in time
um and the government listens so I hope
that the government will listen on this
occasion as well as every indication
that it will and if it needs to make
Savings in order to
pay for these initiatives
um um then you know a number of us have
suggested that whether it's scrapping or
mothballing hs2 which would save tens of
billions or streamlining the Myriad of
quangos that exist which some estimates
suggest cost billions if not tens of
billions then we've got fraud in the
system which we need to eke out
um that would be another few billion at
least I mean you start adding these
figures up and you can more than pay for
the tax cuts they've been announced so
we're trying to be positive as well as
suggest the right course of action in in
um making sure that this
proposal to scrap the linkage between
benefits and inflation is nothing more
than a discussion and the government
will listen and retain that link you're
talking about the need to show fiscal
responsibility and acknowledging the
sense of that we've of course that's
seen what's happened to the markets
again today very very jittery
do you think the government should
consider reversing some of the tax cuts
that it made in the budget to things
such as corporation tax for example
I I we think that if the government was
to reassure markets on both regards to
spending and borrowing and anybody who's
worked in the financial markets as as I
have and many other colleagues have then
it's about it's about reassurance it's
about saying look we know this is going
to cost X but we have proposals in place
and plans to make sure we raise Y and
therefore give the markets a sense of
the extent of the increase in debt don't
forget markets are jittery worldwide
interest rates are going up across the
world
um it's not just in this country that
this is happening
um but those countries don't necessarily
have a strong economy as ours you know
with such record low unemployment as we
have here in this country but even so
the messaging to the markets has to be
spot on it was and am being kind a
little naive the mini budget in almost
rushing the statement out about tax cuts
without those that reassurance to the
markets I think the Prime Minister has
taken that on board I think the
chancellor has and I think you'll see
um you'll see better times ahead
now you will of course be reading the
same newspaper reports as I am you'll be
talking to your colleagues of course uh
as as a member of parliament As You Are
I'm interested to get your honest
opinion on the mood among conservative
backbenches are there serious
conversations going on about potentially
changing the rules the 1922 committee so
that she can be challenged again about
Unity candidates coming forward to
replace her as prime minister is that
seriously happening
well if they are I'm not party to them
um so perhaps so if you're you're nicely
so you're speaking to the wrong person I
if I've got something to say I'll I'll
say it to to them personally
um I won't you know plot or anything
like that so so you'll have to ask other
politicians what I would say though
Sophie is this um there is time
um there is time to to turn this around
um you know if we are calm about it and
we get the get the messaging and the
policies right which I'm sure we will uh
the government is listening uh so there
is time but there isn't time to waste
and I think that's one of the messages
that the government has been receiving
loud and clear in recent days how how
much time Grant shops are 10 days to
turn it around what time frame would you
give
no I don't think it's that short I think
the government has got much more slack
than that but we need to see an
improvement in the messaging in the
policies we need to get the Optics right
but above all else we need to do the
right thing and and when it comes to the
one nation agenda of yes lower taxes to
create a bigger economic pie but that is
not an end in itself it's a means to an
end to better help the less fortunate
that is the one nation agenda that is
compassionate politics compassionate
conservatism and we must not lose sight
of that because we are nothing if we're
not the party of one nation okay thank
you very much great to talk to you this
evening much appreciated
thank you
or we can get a bit more on some of the
Fallout from what does sound like an
extraordinary meeting of concept of MPS
um some capes are Deputy particular
editor it is here uh John Barron uh not
giving us any details of what was behind
closed doors in that meeting but I think
it's pretty clear that there were
several interventions from people who
had perhaps similar concerns as him what
are you hearing so I thought John Barron
sounded quite sanguine really thought
there was a bit of time I can tell you
the mood in the conservative party in
all the conversations I've been having
today is actually moving quite fast I
asked one Tory MP where people's heads
were he just replied in their hands look
I think the 1922 committee with Liz
truss and Tory MPS was quite a
significant moment tonight they thought
it was a bit delusional she basically
blamed all the economic woes on
President Putin and she said that people
weren't just giving her government
enough credit now that rang some alarm
bells and that came after prime
minister's questions where Liz truss
said that absolutely there wouldn't be
spending cut uh under her government now
that actually might technically end up
being true but it's not going to be the
experience of lots and lots of Voters
who will feel the squeeze uh I think
quite sharply in coming months and then
the government this morning was doing a
pretty good impression of having a
public round with the bank of England
which is never a great position for a
government to be in so it's not hard to
find people over drinks and over dinner
plotting basically wondering you know
whether she should go and when she
should go
but you know that's challenging because
you know there are plenty of people who
think that she should be gone
um but they need a Unity candidate there
is a desire amongst the conservative
party if they are to do this not to
allow it to go to the membership for
there to be a divisive and bloody
contest so they're having to work out
how to negotiate that but who on Earth
Sophie would be the unity candidate of a
party this fractious this divided and
this emotional quite frankly so that's
very hard to see
and if that just means the lack of unity
candidate means that there's no way of
breaking out of a deadlock then there is
another option 40 plus Tory MPS could
decide that they're going to vote with
the opposition frankly pull the
emergency cord and trigger a general
election now there would be a
catastrophic defeat of the conservative
party but perhaps it would mean labor
owning potentially one of the most
difficult periods uh that the economy is
going to face but that's what it might
take so it's unclear it's undecided the
economy could get worse Boris Johnson
said that when the herd moves it moves
decisively I think Liz truss has got a
start to watch out 40 MPS needed really
interesting Sam to talk as always Sam
Kate's there giving us a sense of where
the party is at now we were touching on
there about the position of the labor
party here of course are Keen for a
general election we can speak uh well I
speak a little earlier on uh today I
should say to Labor's Shadow business
secretary Jonathan Reynolds this is what
he had to say
so UK borrowing costs have today hit
another 20-year high after the bank of
England confirmed it's going to be
ending its intervention on Friday still
very jittery what does it mean for
Ordinary People well the first thing is
people have seen what it means because
it means High mortgage costs and on
average 500 pounds additional a month
which is a huge burden on families at
any time in a cost of living crisis it's
clearly particularly acute but also
given the government's entire economic
strategy was to was to reduce tax taxes
in some way to give people more spending
power that obviously is going to be
negligible compared to what they're
going to pay for higher mortgages and
I'm afraid you know we're still talking
about the crisis that they've caused
since that many budget say well and it's
getting worse because they're not
acknowledging they are the cause of the
problem so what should happen right now
the only reasonable feasible thing now
I've said to you before I I doubt let's
trust and quasi quite time will ever get
back the confidence they've squandered
so freely but the only available course
of action to them is to immediately say
they will rescind the mini budget and
start again it's really important people
see I think they do that it's not just
about any specific measure this was a
rejection and has been a rejection of
their whole approach how they make
decisions who's in charge their respect
for institutions and you can try and
piece that back together but if you take
what the Prime Minister said and
Promises questions which is absolutely
no spending cuts how can you square that
against the measures that were announced
in that mini budget surely that this has
to mean they are going to revoke it okay
well let's talk about what that actually
means rescinding the the mini budget and
you say that you don't want to talk it's
not about specific measures but often it
is about specific measures as well right
and I'm just quite Keen to find out what
labor would do you know you want to
position yourselves as a future
government ready government waiting if
you like well let's have a little look
about what you would do uh then so would
you keep say 60 billion pounds energy
price freeze yes we were the ones who
said you have to freeze Energy prices we
led the way on that so 60 billion pounds
that that would be spent by labor on
this well we were clear that we
supported the government's intervention
and called for it to take place even
though the conservative leadership
contest said they wouldn't so we support
freezing energy bills we've said before
borrowing for a crisis is fine boring to
invest is fine what you can't borrow for
are unfunded tax cuts okay and let's
talk about some of those unfunded tax
cards you confirm that you would keep
the 1p cuts in the basic rate of tax
correct yes we would and how about a
National Insurance would you also commit
to reversing that high connection well
we never supported it going up so should
we've been consistent and we wouldn't
have had that so you're talking there
you I just I just want to and I know
there's other things we can get on to
but some of the biggest measures in that
budget you were committed to keeping or
doing exactly the same on whether it's
spending a lot of money on NG or whether
it's spending a lot of money that's why
that's why it's so important people
understand this was not for instance the
top rate of tax triggering the lack of
Market conference this is about the
people there how they make decisions
their respect for institutions their
respect for policy making and indeed
their overall philosophy which is you
can borrow money to pay for unfunded tax
cuts but you're talking about keeping
some of those unpundered which has been
consistent in everything that we have
said our plan first of all we would
raise more Revenue we said that things
like ending that the non-dom rule brings
another three billion pounds we've said
we wouldn't allow private schools to be
Charities we don't believe that's a
reasonable assessment of their status
these bring in sources of revenue
at the same time our plans for the
economy industrial strategy reforming
business rates improving our trading
relationship with the single Market
these are all genuine things that you
can point to and expect some economic
uptick from it's different from just a
vague hope that trickle-down economic
mix will will do it I would also say
however and this is crucial I would not
accept the spending envelope created by
Liz truss and quasi quattank because it
is precisely the lack of confidence in
them that has made the fiscal picture
look so challenging because it means
higher borrowing costs for government it
means you know huge ramifications from
uh government borrowing costs causing
more debt repayment and for future
spending projects so I believe
absolutely the minute you replace
quasiquartang and Liz trust with Keith
starmer and Rachel Reeves you have more
confidence in this country going forward
and in the spending plans of government
so just to be clear because you say you
wouldn't um you wouldn't keep the same
spending envelope are you saying that
labor would spend more on public
services well I think economic growth
would be higher and I base that on our
plans and on the fact that economic
growth was higher under the last Labor
government I think that is an absolutely
fair and consistent picture we've got
plans on it question the question is
would you spend more on public services
than this government well we would only
spend on public services on Revenue
spending what comes in in taxation we
have plans for additional investment
around things like tackling climate
change and good jobs and Net Zero but
we've been very clear but having those
fiscal rules having a commitment to
responsibility I would say makes the
overall envelope better because you you
don't produce the kind of spook markets
which the mini budget did so our plans
our fiscal rules are absolutely
sacrosanct sometimes people criticize us
for that they want to see us make bigger
commitments in certain areas but I think
the entire approach by Kieran Rachel has
been validated by what you've seen in
response to the mini budget um I'm still
forgive me slightly unclear on whether
you you would you spend more on public
services you think then but we would
bring in more revenue and then we could
spend more on public services but it
can't be unfunded and it can't be
borrowing money today and so how how
would you bring in this Revenue because
if you're saying that you know you want
to bring down borrowing and I get that
you know we're currently spending more
on debt interest payments in the
education budget you know there's clear
pressure from the markets to do that and
but you want to keep the 16 billion
pound energy price guarantee you want to
keep the 1p cut to the basic tax you
want to keep the reversal of the
National Insurance hike
the things that you've talked about you
know ending the private school
charitable status it's not going to
touch the size is it well bringing in
more revenue is crucial if you want to
spend more money and that's why we
hypothecate everything that we want to
do to a source of Revenue I mean I would
say I understand people going down you
know the government's proposal of the
mini budget what's the position all of
them I frankly feel by Friday by with
the weekend this might be moot because
if the government is going to stick to
what Liz trust said at Prime Minister's
questions I cannot possibly see how
those measures are still in place at
that point but look we we believe
economic growth would be higher we've
got more tangible and realistic plans
for economic growth and real policy
interventions than the government we've
been very clear we bring in additional
sources of revenue and have law
borrowing through a more expansive
windfall tax but fundamentally our
commitment to those fiscal rules has
always been important to me and I think
the whole country now sees why you need
a government committed to fiscal
responsibility and unfortunately what
happens when you have a government that
isn't
um you obviously want to see a general
election you think you sat here and told
me that on this program before no
surprise when you look at the polls do
you think you'll be facing Liz truss for
the next general election well it's hard
to say I mean I do want a general
election because I genuinely as I've
said to you before think that is the
only way you square the problems the
government have created I would quite
frankly like a general election and a
change of government before I have to do
my my own end of my fixed rate mortgage
quite frankly because I think there's a
personal consequence these days for all
of us when's that happening then I think
it's in 2024 so hopefully um well we'll
see but look
can we realistically have a fifth failed
conservative prime minister without any
kind of democratic say in that I I
cannot see how they can do that I cannot
see how they could form a realistic
government uniting the different parts
of the conservative party around that so
I would say for them as well they need a
general election to resolve their own
problems and surely that is the only way
forward to break the malaise that we're
in let's try said today it's the last
thing we want to see I think the last
thing let's trust wants to see and I
think we can understand that but
realistically what what is Liz trust
offering you know it's been 12 years of
pain for a lot of people in this country
she herself recognizes that she sent out
what she says is a different path but
look at the consequences of that and
frankly she could for instance perform a
U-turn another U-turn I mean there are
so many u-turns for her brand which is
supposed to be sticking to what she
always wants to do and believes in I
think that has been challenged says she
sucks the chancellor
he's only doing what she wanted he's got
a reasonable point to make that he
hasn't done something the prime minister
is unhappy with she she embodies this
kind of politics and has made that very
clear so how can she do that and regain
the credibility that has been lost
that's why I think a change of
government is the only realistic Way
Forward
Jonathan Reynolds there are giving
Labor's take well we are live in
Westminster view for you this evening up
next we're going to be hearing our pmq
of the week where we give it back then
to a chance to respond to the prime
minister
[Music]
now there's been reports that Liz truss
blocked plans for a public information
campaign to help people reduce their
energy usage well that was what we
thought but then the former conservative
Minister guy Opperman asked this at Pim
Keys earlier
prime minister the
the price guarantees
it's a good plan but too few businesses
and households know about it even if the
labor party don't support it can I urge
you to have a nationwide mail out
campaign to communicate what the
government is doing to assess people on
reduction or energy and more
particularly I have a reduction of
energy campaign by the public service so
that we don't go down the route we're
spending too much on consumption we
reduce Supply
well my my um my right audible friend is
absolutely right and I know the energy
secretary is working on a plan to help
companies and individuals use energy
more efficiently we're also working on
this across government I was delighted
to speak to my friend yesterday and I
hope we'll be able to start this going
in number 10 straight away
well there you go what is going on we
can hear now from the conservative MP
who got that response I asked guy
Opperman about a potential public
information campaign
so it's a campaign I've been running for
some time I think the energy price
guarantee is a phenomenal piece of
policy it is groundbreaking it is a
massive assistance but I don't believe
necessarily everybody knows about it to
the extent they need to do so I want to
have a nationwide mail out campaign to
communicate that so that everybody has a
full understanding of the support the
government is giving and secondly then I
raised with the PM to copy what the
Germans the French and Italians are
doing which is to reduce energy
consumption by the state so putting it
bluntly you turn every boiler to 19
degrees throughout any public building
you turn off lights after 10 pm in
certain circumstances you do stuff
safely obviously but at the same stage
the Germans reckon they can cut their
energy consumption by about two percent
by doing that now that produces huge
savings it is also something that will
produce Savings in terms of the taxpayer
subsidy because of course the energy
price guarantee is effectively an
underwriting of all our household builds
all the business bills for a long period
of time but if we manage people to get
people to use less energy then the
subsidy becomes less which gives the
chancellor some savings on a long-term
basis and what um what did you make of
the prime minister's answer to your
question were you satisfied with them uh
well listen I saw her last night and I
also raised this with the chancellor
yesterday and I raised it with the
business secretary Jacob B smog
um I believed it was very positive and
the indications are that such a campaign
will happen and the indications are that
the public sector will be asked to take
a differing approach on a longer term
basis I'm also interested in whether you
think we've been talking about business
and estate cutting its usage whether you
think there should be a campaign around
families cutting their usage as well
there's obviously been reports that Liz
trust blocked a proposed 50 million
pound campaign from the Department for
business to try and I guess a public
information campaign to try and help
families reduce their energy consumption
well I think it's a bit unfair on the PM
because literally this producer was
produced very recently and this is
something that has been a work in
progress I've been making the case to uh
government that this is something we
should do and I think basically this
should be a communication to everybody
and we all are going to be affected by
Putin's energy war against us and we
need to make sure that everybody has a
differing approach in your party I guess
though some would say it would be a bit
of a nanny State approach to interfere
if you like and tell people how to run
their households it's not you're not
telling people to do that what you're
doing is you're a explaining what
government is already doing and in that
respect there's no telling whatsoever
and secondly what you can do is you can
can refer them to information whether
that's to Martin Lewis's website or to
The Regulators website or the stuff
that's already ongov.uk now to reduce
their own personal business that's not
saying you have to do it it's just
saying look there is this options and
assistance is out there
um I want to talk a bit more right about
pmqs as well because one of the kind of
headlines if you like to come out of it
was with Liz truss asked if she was
going to stick to her promise to not cut
uh spending she said absolutely do you
think that's the right way forward yes I
do in the in this particular
circumstances yes I do and I think she
is being very honest with the British
people and should be supported and
applauded for her approach
um I guess the thing that I'm slightly
confused about is you know you have a
Chancellor who's promised a fully costed
plan to get debt falling in the medium
term a prime minister who says there
won't be any spending cards any
government that says they're not going
to utan on any more of the tax accounts
that they've seen so how does that all
add up well I think the position is that
the chancellor is going to have to sit
down with the OB are he's going to have
to sit down with the Parliamentary party
and he's also going to have to be in a
position to set out how he does that he
has 17 days to do that and we should get
behind him in that process I do
personally believe that um there is a
greater degree of realization that you
know you can't be a free marketeer
unless you understand and appreciate the
impact of the markets and clearly we
need to work with markets we need to
work with Regulators in the obr and
that's something that I think is being
done you said there's a realization what
do you sort of mean by that well I think
listen uh clearly the prime ministers
accepted her communication could
potentially have been better that is
something that we're working on there
has been very good progress made over
the last week or two to expel out
exactly what this is all about I think
our discussion today about the energy
price guarantee which is the key part of
the growth plan as announced in the mini
budget that is something that is utterly
vital because without it without this
government intervention thousands and
thousands of businesses in household
would have gone bankrupt this winter now
that is the sort of stuff that we need
to communicate better
do you think that any of the tax cuts
should be rolled back well I think
listen it's got to be
once he's been in a position that he sat
down with the obr once he's looked at
the growth plan and clearly we're going
to have to do a balancing exercise on an
ongoing basis but one of the reasons why
I'm in favor of an energy price
guarantee Communications package and a
reduction of consumption is it gives him
savings if we can do the two percent
savings that the Germans think they can
do then that is less subsidy that is
less consumption uh less inflation and
his fiscal Position will improve now I'm
hopeful that that will be something that
will be communicated and worked through
with the obr over the next two weeks
um now I hope you obviously like in the
leadership campaign you were a pensions
Minister before um being asked to leave
that position
just talk me through if you don't mind
it how was that did you get a phone call
what what happened well that's A Private
Matter it can be perfectly Fair that's a
perfectly Private Matter that you know
and the prime minister is entitled to go
forward with her team and I back her
wholeheartedly I really want the prime
minister to succeed I think the entire
conservative party wants the prime
minister to succeed and as does in my
view the nation because it doesn't
really matter which country you are
presently sitting in you can be in
France or Germany or Italy or even
America they are all going through the
similar problems now you can say oh well
this policy wasn't quite as tweaked as
well as it should have done or this
policy wasn't done as quite well as well
as it should have been done that's
irrelevant in factual reality every
leader has got the same issues across
the world at present stage and I
sincerely hope the prime minister is
successful in guiding this country
forward do you think that their talk
about rebellions if you like it among
your peers they're a bit over egged then
yes
foreign
cues and it was the first prime
minister's questions in over a month for
Liz trust so let's get the take now of
our political correspondent Joe Pike
this is always one of my favorite parts
of the show this is pmq's unwrapped
today was only Liz truss's second pmqs
and a lot has happened since her first
we've had the energy bills package the
death of the queen a mini budget chaos
in the financial markets a u-turn on the
top rate of tax and today an unexpected
shrinkage of the UK economy so no
surprise that even before today's
session started conservative whips were
working hard to avoid any empty seats
and asking their colleagues to fill gaps
on the green benches one was even told
to leave and re-enter on the opposite
side of the chamber before taking his
place if we look at the first four rows
around Liz truss and highlight the
ministers
than the government whips and finally
the Parliamentary private secretaries
almost all cheering the pm today are on
her payroll
there was no sign of quasi-quarting on
the front bench as he is in the U.S
perhaps a relief for the chancellor
because kistama had no choice but to
focus on the economy
ducking responsibility lost in denial no
wonder investors have no confidence in
her government does she think the public
will ever forgive the conservative party
if they keep on defending this madness
and go ahead with a Kamikaze budget Liz
truss's tactic was to sidestep most of
those questions and retaliate by
highlighting her package of support on
energy bills
we have taken decisive action to make
sure that people are not facing energy
bills of six thousand pounds talks about
our spending which he doesn't seem to
support on the energy price guarantee
but unlike her predecessor Liz trusted
on the whole provide answers confirming
she would go ahead with Banning no fault
evictions and providing an unexpected
answer on public spending
during her leadership contest the Prime
Minister said and I quote her exactly
I'm very clear I'm not planning public
spending reductions
is she going to stick to that yeah
absolutely absolutely
[Applause]
look Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker
there were murmurs laughs even a few
gasps in the chamber at that moment
confusion as to how that would all add
up perhaps not a market calming moment
and one phrase from the prime minister
went down so well with labor she
delivered it twice
I'm genuinely unclear
Mr Speaker I'm genuinely unclear
on our
Eddie the final pmq from a labor MP was
a reminder of the inevitable a general
election
two percent of
once an immediate general election
the Prime Minister claims she's in
listening mode we should give way to the
public yeah yeah
Mr Speaker I think the last thing we
need is a general election
[Applause]
today was a bruising encounter for a
prime minister already in political pain
some of her MPS are now suggesting
further u-turns on tax and in response
number 10 has told us difficult
decisions will be needed but this trust
is not reconsidering measures from her
mini budget
well that was Joe's take on the commons
this afternoon so what do people
watching on Sky News make for all we can
now go to our viewers panel to try and
find out hello everyone hopefully you're
going to be appearing right now as if by
Magic there you are lovely to see you
all and thanks very much be on the show
tonight well just to start off we just
heard Liz truss say there at pmqs the
last thing anyone wants is a general
election should we put it to the test
what about you guys uh do you would you
like to see a general election if you'd
like to see a general election now or
shortly put your hand up if you would
like to see a general election
three of you and okay and if you
wouldn't if you don't think now's the
right time or you're sick of Elections
put your hands up now
so that's three so perfectly split there
we go completely divided on whether or
not that should be an election right
let's dig a bit deeper into some of the
issues uh shall we uh where are we going
first um
where are we going
Roz first excellent box one here we go
let's talk to Rose I just always waiting
for direction for my producers who got
like he's the boss here so uh right here
we go Roz uh you say that you would like
to see a general election why is that
well this government's a disaster
um it hasn't got a mandate nobody nobody
has voted for this
except I think a a a few hundred
thousand uh toy party members
lose trust has managed to completely
sink the economy
um and that's after 12 years of Tory
government that have destroyed Public
Services destroyed communities
um mishandled just about everything and
it really is time now for a general
election it's very very clear from
opinion polls that there is a massive
anti-toy majority and that is not
surprising given the chaos and disaster
that we've had over the last 12 years
culminating in the two worst Prime
Ministers that I can remember in my
lifetime I mean nobody I think believed
it was possible to be worse than Boris
Johnson
but Liz is managing it I think it was
The Economist that said she's got the
shelf life of a lettuce it's uh it's bad
and for the sake of the markets for the
sake of our economy for the sake of our
country and actually for the sake of the
Tory party themselves we need a general
election okay Rose very clear there
would like to see a general election
let's talk to Chloe shall we I'm always
interested here uh what Chloe has to say
uh from Cumbria talking to us Chloe now
you voted conservative under Boris
Johnson would you vote for the
conservatives if there was an election
tomorrow
no absolutely not
and why is that
um it's just chaos isn't it it's it's
cringy to almost to watch
um like the pmqs now and and they've
just it's like they've lost control
completely of of what's going on around
them
well again it's interesting to hear you
know Chloe again saying that she can't
support other conservatives at the
minute like Roars let's go bring in Tim
shall we and now it's the first time
we've spoken to you on the program Tim
so thanks very much for joining us
um you're talking to us from Perth uh
you are a conservative voter what's your
view on Liz trust do you think that her
time is up or do you think that actually
people aren't giving her a chance to
share what she's all about
I don't think anyone's giving her enough
time for anything to bed in yet and I
think she should just be given the
amount of time the energy cap for me and
my family is is going to save us a lot
of money over the Christmas period day
and what would your message be for MPS
then because some of their own MPS
aren't happy with the job she's doing
well they just need to get behind doing
show a support that's the problem with
what happened with Boris Johnson
everyone turned on him I think that we
just need to give at least Justice a
part in the time and let's see how it
goes uh really interested to talk and
the point that you're making about the
sailing on energy bills I think that's
something that people will be able to
understand as well I want to bring in
Hannah now Hannah who's talking to us
from Hartford today now you were talking
to my producer Jared about mortgages and
it's something that's been affecting you
personally I think it's always good to
talk about this because you know we
speak about what's happening in the
markets as if it's something that just
happens and doesn't affect people but
obviously there is a real impact on
people just tell us what's happening
with you
well we're looking to sell our house and
to buy a bigger property and we're just
really concerned with uh whether we'll
be able to get a big enough mortgage now
because I know that mortgage lenders
some of them have also don't lending
less money also are the prices inflated
too much is there going to be a house
price crash that is something of great
concern to us because obviously we don't
want to take on more debt and then find
ourselves in negative equity so
you know we can stay put it's not the
end of the world absolutely but you know
I think for a lot of people are looking
to move or even get onto the housing
market is this the right time
you know to me even I'm not sure it is I
think we might well just stay and wait
it out and see what happens because
I don't know what Liz truss is doing and
I'm not sure she does either uh it was
interesting to hear their sort of real
world sort of impact of that and I'm
sure lots of people will be making
similar decisions uh to you who of
course as you say you know do have the
choice at least over what they they do
let's bring in Stella now shall we
Stella Findlay uh for talking to us from
Newcastle now initially Stella you were
quite skeptical of uh listra has she won
you over at all
um I wouldn't say she's won me over
exactly but I think she did quite well
at Prime Minister's question time
um I think she wrong footed Kia stama at
one point
um and I think we aren't giving her a
chance it's it's as though we're each
seeing a different person there but
um I think we've had so much turmoil in
the country recently that the last thing
we want as she said is a general
election and I think we should give her
a chance and
um and see what she comes up with she
they have made mistakes but
maybe she's learned from those mistakes
maybe she can write them and there is a
global crisis so it isn't as though
we're unique in that
um even the IMF have said that we might
be heading for a global recession so we
aren't alone in suffering in this way
right let's bring in Rob for a final
word shall we uh Rob brief word from you
you're a conservative from Bolton do you
agree that Liz trust should be given a
bit more time
a little bit more time yes I wouldn't
mind seeing though some kind of
Coalition on the energy crisis no no
whether whether neighbor would um would
want to enter into that in the SOP
because I know that they want a general
action as to many of the electorates but
they should be very very careful what
the wish got because they might just get
it
okay and how would you vote it just just
so one word would be answer how would
you vote if there was a night election
tomorrow
uh conservative okay great thank you so
much really interesting uh to talk to
all of you big Divergence of views as
always on the panel which is what we
like to see uh thank you very much for
giving up your Wednesday night cheers
well as we've been saying it has been
all eyes on the economy again today the
cost of government borrowing soaring
again earlier as guilt prices fell and
that of course as the bank of England
Governor said he wouldn't be providing
more support markets worried about a
black hole in the public finances there
was also news of the economy shrinking
in August well let's bring in our next
guest uh shall we can talk now to The
Economist uh Vicki price who is joining
us from Athens and thank you so much for
being with us we'll forgive you for not
being in the studio if you're in Athens
it does feel like a very good reason and
to be unable to talk to us
um I'm really interested to know your
take on where we are today more alarming
news about the cost of government
borrowing soaring the Market's still
very jittery How concerned should we be
foreign
Market will do after that who knows I
think must we depend on whether the
issues with Pension funds have been
sorted out in between there may not have
been but even if they have the market
will test I think the government will
test the bank of England's resolve not
to intervene again so the expectation is
that the bank of England probably will
have to intervene at some point again
and the big issue in the market is it's
going to be what comes up on October the
31st when we get the final workings of
the official budget responsibility
looking at what the spending plans and
tax plans are likely to be of the
government and then pronouncing whether
they're sustainable and whatever other
measures perhaps the chancellor comes up
with there is speculation and maybe
there will be more u-turns to come or
perhaps some postponement of some of the
tax cuts that were planned to happen
next year here a lot is up in the air
and I think the markets will be testing
uh the particularly the bond market
resolve the bank of England it was
interesting to hear as trust up prime
minister's questions today saying that
she would absolutely stick to her pledge
for no spending cuts obviously of course
we know that with inflation uh real
terms Cuts could be coming anyway but
that said if she is willing to you know
overall uh protect the spending envelope
does that mean that what we're actually
looking at as you say is a perhaps a
deferral of some of the tax cuts that
were announced and would that be enough
to calm the markets
there may be I mean it depends of course
how long you defer them for but also
there are some underlying positive
things that could perhaps be on the side
of the government uh which are in
particular at the price that we're
paying right now for energies not just
gas but it's also more generally so
there is this pledge of course to keep
the electricity price cap for households
and also for businesses up to a point
for the next few months for businesses
two years for households that of course
has been costed as you know really quite
expensive foray into extra borrowing
that we need to be done in order to be
able to fund this now the question is
how much borrowing there might need to
be the expectation has been that
certainly for this year maybe an extra
60 billion uh which will bring the
financial years borrowing to
considerably greater double what had
been anticipated originally
but we may see the gas prices which have
fallen quite significantly recently may
stay low and if there is the case then
what we might find is that the cost of
that electricity price freeze is
considerably lower than have been
anticipated in terms of what the
government may need to put in in terms
of support of that price so if that were
to happen then we might find that maybe
what the government needs to do in terms
of how many bonds it may need to issue
in the markets might be less than a bit
anticipated and maybe that will satisfy
the market but there's so many maybes in
that symptoms that I've just given that
the markets are not going to be
satisfied with just that possibility now
I wonder if you could help me out with
something because when I have my
interviews to the government what they
always say to me is that look these are
Global forces
um they're looking at Global inflation
they're looking at the war with Putin
they say look all currencies are weak
against the dollar so it's not fair to
look at that
is there truth in that or are they
trying to spin it
there is some truth in that there is no
doubt that the dollar has been rather
strong recently the main reason for that
is that they had started upping their
own interest rates a lot earlier than
others and they've been raising them
quite aggressively recently and the
expectation is that they will continue
to do so so yes I think there is a
General Dollar strength but what we've
seen in particular with Sterling is that
Sterling has suffered from what's been
happening recently very significantly we
would not have seen that type of decline
that we saw after the mini budget was
announced just on interest rate
differentials because in fact if
anything uh what the mini budget did or
will do if it gets implemented is add
extra money into the economy extra
liquidity which would if anything be
pushing up inflation which anyone would
have assumed would suggest that the bank
of England would raise interest rates
even more aggressively well you know if
you look though at what Sterling did is
done the opposite if you like it has
assumes that there's going to be you
know a lot of uncertainty in the markets
and and I think the bank of England was
tested at that time and they did the
right thing their intervention of course
the markets which completely reversed
what they said they were going to do
when the raisins were traced by 50 basis
points just before the budget itself a
day earlier
um they were going to start selling
their own Bonds in the market that they
have on their balance sheets because
they've been accumulating loads when
they were supporting the government
through the covert period because that
was really how they managed to keep
yields low and therefore the borrowing
costs quite low they did the opposite of
what they say they were going to do just
a day earlier they went out in the
market instead and started buying yields
but that is the thumbs down really on
the mini budget you know there's no
other way in which you can describe it
so I think the mini budget most
definitely uh has been the cause of what
we've seen recently okay thank you
always interesting uh to talk to people
you so thank you for sharing some of
your knowledge with us thank you
your price there well we've had plenty
of takes this evening we'll have a bit
of post-match round up with our Deputy
political editor Sam cakes is here again
uh good to see you again Sam I mean it
feels doesn't it that it's right to end
the program looking at the state of the
economy and it's talking there to Vicky
price about it and really that is a big
story today you know talking to our
panelists who said look I can't get a
mortgage now I'm just going to stay put
because the rates are just uh going
crazy and that's a real world I guess
what's happening isn't it that's right I
mean it's really hard to overstate how
serious the situation is with the global
economy with the domestic economy and
with the financial system which is
obviously part of the economy but is
currently wobbling a bit and if you look
at the hurdles just in the next 48 hours
they're massive
two weeks ago the bank of England had to
step in and provide emergency support
for Pension funds because there was a
chance that within hours they'd go bust
that emergency support ends the governor
of the bank of England told us last
night on Friday nobody knows what's
going to happen on Friday whether or not
the problem that they saw trying to fix
is fixed or whether something altogether
worse might happen or whether the bank
of England just keeps on with its
emergency help absolutely no sign of
clarity on that and if there is some
kind of big problem at that moment
nobody's quite sure whether it's just
related to Pension funds or whether it
might affect Banks or Insurance firms so
all of a sudden we could be facing in
quite short order some very very serious
problems quite apart from all the
politics that we've been talking about
but then there are ever ever then there
are other economic problems that I think
people are struggling with and that is
how Liz trust makes all her sums add up
particularly in relation to that mini
budget now a little detail from tonight
at the 19 22 Liz trust promised to bring
her MPS on board with regional round
tables to determine what should and
shouldn't go in the spending cuts to be
announced on October 31st she's handing
over control for her MPS but her MPS all
disagree to how she's going to make the
figure that she needs to to reassure the
markets at the end of the month just the
Urgent economic questions in relation to
this month alone feel very difficult
indeed yes certainly it is a very quick
thought from you Sam how safe do you
think the chancellor is
at the moment the chancellor is a human
shield for Liz truss the tax cuts were
her decision as well as his interesting
thank you so much Sam always good to get
your analysis uh there well that is it
for the take another a really big week
that important 22 committee meeting will
be back next week when of course we'll
find out the results of what did happen
on Friday as Sam is saying every week
obviously Wednesday at 9pm and next up
it is Sky News at 10. thanks for
watching hopefully see you on Sunday
morning as well
[Music]
foreign